بما هو اهم ما جاء فيها مسلمي خاصه حينما
قال بان المؤسسه العسكريه ستعترف بالقياده
السياسيه للسياسيين ولكن على السياسيين
ايضا ان اا يتركوا جوانب فنيه اعصاب
المهمه العسكريه للمؤسسه العسكريه ولا
يتدخل فيها كما يبدو يبدو ان هذا الامر
همم ربما حسن جدلا كبيرا كان سابقا ولكن
يبقى يحتاج الى المزيد من التفاصيل همم
خاصه ما يتعلق فيها
بالصلاحيات التي ستحضى بها المؤسسه
العسكريه وفقه هذا الموضوع سلام سلام
نعم هو اكد على ما كان يقوله احيانا وهو
ان
تاكيده على ان ما سبق اكده ان وجود
المؤسسه العسكريه في السلطه وفي السياسه
وجود مؤقت تمليه ظروف معينه وانهم بهذا
الاتفاق او ما اسماء التوافق هو يريد به
هو والذين وقع هذا الاتفاق ان يؤسسوا الى
الى مبادئ عامه الى العلاج الازمه الوطنيه
كلها واكد على ان الاصل في المؤسسه
العسكريه الذي ستلتزم به هو خروجها عن
السياسه وان الغايات الكبرى للوطن الخاصه
الغايات الامنيه يضعوها السياسيون وتلتزم
بها المؤسسه العسكريه ولكن على السياسيين
ان يحترم مهنيه المؤسسه العسكريه والله
يتدخل في التفاصيل الفنيه التي تعرفها
المؤسسه العسكريه وايضا قال ان هذا
الاتفاق همم لا يحجر على الذين لم يوقعوا
عليه بعد ان ان يلتحق به وهذه دعوه بشكل
ما الى ان الذين
عارضوا هذا الاتفاق لا تزال عندهم الفرصه
للالتحاق بهذا الاتفاق الايطالي وان هذا
الاتفاق الايطالي يريد ان يقود الفتره
الانتقاليه بالوصول اليها بالوصول بها الى
اي انتخابات حره ونزيهه وان المؤسسه
العسكريه لن تخذل الشعب السوداني وستظل
ايوه راعيه الى مصالح هذا الشعب السوداني
وايضا ااه اتجاه الى ان هذا الاتفاق ينبغي
ان ينبغي عليه علاقات جويه جديده ينبغي ان
ترفع العقوبات عن السودان كليه وينبغي ان
ان تعاد عضويه السودان في الاتحاد
الافريقي بناء على هذا الاتفاق وينبغي ان
يدعم هذا الاتفاق ماديا وماليا حتى يستطيع
ان يصل الى الى
اهدافه واخيرا اكد على شكريه على كل الذين
ساهموا في هذا الاتفاق وخاصه القوى
الاقليميه دفعت في هذا الاتفاق ولكن يظل
السؤال الذي يظل باستمرار هو قدره الحكم
المدني قدره الانتقال بهذا الاتفاق الى
حكم مدني ذا فاعليه وكفاءه وهذا طبعا
يتوقف على موقف الاطراف التي عرضت هذا
الاتفاق سلم الكباشي اشكرك همم مسلمين
كباشي مدير مكتب الجزيره